tomorrow is international tea day a day
that seller it's celebrated across the
globe and here to show us the proper way
to celebrate here in las vegas our tea
specialists jack layal and valentino jr
both from mod 32 inside the venetian
welcome you guys thank you
thanks for having us appreciate it my
first question what is it what is a tea
master what is a tea specialist well
team master uh require the credentials
and some certification uh t specialists
like me it's just a person really like
tea and i've been studying uh tea for
many years so you've been studying teams
yeah you know your team yeah and then uh
i do
um i'm an expert on the tea service in
our restaurant it's a format 32. okay if
someone wants to host the tea party
let's talk about the do's and don'ts of
having a tea party if you're the host of
a tea party what are some of the do's
when hosting a tea party or serving tea
yeah most definitely one of the things
that uh jack definitely taught me
especially when you're pouring tea one
of the funniest things i ever learned
was when somebody's pouring tea and they
do this to you it doesn't mean to stop
pouring them tea
i've done that once and they look at me
why are you stopping
but initially it's actually a bow a
gesture of thank you for pouring the tea
for me okay so it's not hit me give me a
21. you're thanking the person without
the person right from the team okay and
there's a few other gestures too if
you'd like to go a little over yeah
definitely so uh when we uh serve the
tea to always serve to the host of the
party first and then we use two hands a
second respectful when serving that yeah
okay yeah because the tea service
traditional tea service is very
it's meant to be very elegant
calm and relaxing and it's an experience
yeah yeah it's like
it's a whole experience that we're going
through yeah as you'd like me to show
you yeah please go ahead and demonstrate
okay so the first time
first one we did here is uh to warm up
the tea cup
and what are some of the spices that you
can put in our tea here today uh spices
oh no this is actually the tea leaves
yeah the tea sorry so uh so this is i am
not a tea specialist so this is a the
age pour mm-hmm is the type of black tea
that we have uh it goes really great
with like seafood and some spicy food
okay yeah and cinnamon tea right here is
the
the tea leaf there without any caffeine
in there okay it's more flour uh it's
great with the dessert dessert and stuff
uh and we have the white tea which is
silver needle the white is lightly
fermented it's a little different with
the green tea but it's very rich in with
the antioxidant
in the tea and this one is the
dragonball jasmine which is our most
popular tea
it has the jasmine taste and green tea
help the digestion and everything the
presentation is beautiful so start to
how do you make the tea oh yeah so this
one is the ui hong pao this is one of
our deluxe tea that i'm going to
demonstrate over here for our tea
services okay it's a it's called the
kung fu tea services so i already went
up the cup with the hot water
and so what i do is just putting
tea into a little bowl
yeah in here
and then i can do our tea leaving
here it's ideal about like six grain
okay like one one serve okay
and then when you do it
you kind of do it a circle
not direct to the tea leaves i'm picking
up so many little tidbits here for my
tea i'm a direct form well it's
important you keep the second hand on
top too it's it's very important it's
part of the uh the whole style of
pouring the tea so the second step what
we're doing right now is color rinsing
the tea
so we just rinse out tea a little bit
how many different teas do you have a
thirty two month uh thirty two months
about like ten ten different tea okay
it's about like five types okay
i gotta toss it to break here is this
the final product
uh yes this is so this is all ready to
drink right now uh no no no no oh
actually no yeah sorry so we're doing a
rinsing right now oh we're cleaning
we're cleaning our teeth yeah we're
pouring in exactly
so we're just doing the rinsing
and after rinsing
the cup is nice and warm
okay you can actually uh smell the
cheese i'm gonna smell it here and then
i do i do have to toss it a break guys
that smells so good international tea
day is tomorrow you can celebrate at
home or better yet go see you guys
32 actually ma 32 is located at the
venetian and that's the venetian resorts
in las vegas right on the palazzo floor
we have really good teas obviously we
also have teas that cocktails that have
tea in it and come for the peaking duck
as well i love it awesome gentlemen
thank you very much las vegas now we
will be right back